[Music]
Oh Steve Jobs autobiography
hello everybody so today we are going to
talk about 5 tips to increasing your
productivity tip number one leverage the
power of habits to build productive
routines I asked you guys for book
recommendations on Twitter and one of
the books I got was the power of habit
now I actually started listening to the
audiobook of it and I thought it was
really interesting because it helped me
understand how I became more productive
in the past year and now that I can
pinpoint that it was because I was
building a habit out of the things I
wanted to be productive on that I was
able to make a routine and start
cranking out code videos work stuff you
name it now essentially what you want to
do is for the next 21 days do something
every day this could be coding flossing
or whatever you want that you think is
productive and after 21 days it will be
so hard for you to stop that will become
second nature to you tip number two
start multitasking the mundane stuff for
things that doesn't require much
concentration to do do something else
that's more productive while you do that
it would save you surprisingly a lot of
time for example when I clean my room or
do something super boring that I usually
do not like at all I would just you know
whip out an audio book and just start
listening to it and that way I can
actually learn stuff while I do those
mundane tasks another example would be
when I brush my teeth I would read
emails or I would check my social media
accounts and then little by little I'm
actually saving a lot of time in the
long run tip number three keep yourself
busy and accountable with deadlines and
stakeholders now one of the things I
like to do is actually to fill out my
calendar with lots of focus blocks and
deadlines that way I barely have time to
procrastinate the deadlines I set for
myself or even better that I promised to
other people will keep me accountable
for actually completing the projects
that way I can't procrastinate because I
just have a lot to finish and a lot of
people are dependent on me to finish
them
tip number four when taking a break
don't think about work
just have fun this is important because
I see a lot of people half-ass their
productive time but they also have has
their fun time for example I see a lot
of people studying while watching TV
shows that's terrible because you end up
not enjoying the show nor learning the
things are trying to learn so when I
give myself a break I make sure I don't
think about anything else I love TV
shows so I turn off my phone and immerse
myself and surprisingly you'll actually
learn a lot more by doing that like for
example I love to watch kpop videos and
actually learn a lot of cinematography
by dissecting these videos and just
focusing on it but if I was coding while
watching these kpop videos I'd never
appreciate them as much tip number five
exercise exercise exercise now I'm a big
fan of weightlifting so I might be
biased here but I truly believe that
exercising will make you sharper
exercising helps you relieve stress
because it releases endorphins which are
feel-good hormones that way it allows
you to refresh your mind and be a lot
more productive throughout the day it
doesn't even need to be super intense as
long as you get your heart rate up and
work on moving your body more you'll
feel the benefits right away exercise is
a powerful habit and can be a good
primer to you know teaching you to how
to build these productive habits so I
highly recommend going to the gym or
exercising regularly so in conclusion
the most important point I want to get
across is that if you really want to be
good at something or you want to change
an aspect of your life then make it a
habit now you might say oh yeah it's not
as easy as it sounds though and you're
absolutely right you know building
habits extremely hard and I find it hard
myself but if you really care about the
thing you want to achieve then you will
put the effort into it and that's why I
want to keep myself accountable for what
I say and I want you guys to join me so
basically choose something that you
always wanted to do or something that
you want to get good at and together
we'll make it a new habit so for me this
is running I hate running every aspect
of it I'm also extremely bad at it but
that's also why I want to work on it I
want to have better cardio and since I
hate running the most I want to confront
it
and if I can make running a habit then
it gives me the confidence that in the
future I can make anything a habit I
also want to thank audible for
sponsoring this video and I wanted to
also recommend the audio book the power
of habit which I talked a lot about in
this video and when you sign up for a
free 30-day trial inaudible today at
audible.com slash Joma you can go and
get that audio book that book really
helped me become more productive and
deconstruct the idea of habits and it's
great because now why I run this summer
I can listen to it so I don't need to
sit down and have a dedicated reading
time they also have a huge library of
other audiobooks you can listen to so if
you want to get a free 30-day trial you
can get it at audible.com slash Joma or
you can text Joma
to 500 500 so thank you audible again
for allowing me to make this video and I
hope you guys enjoyed it and don't
forget to smash that like button and
subscribe please
[Music]
because it goes through the holes you
keep sleeping on the couch